you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is around
two game from the 2016 Bilbao masters
final between way playing on the white
end and magnus carlsen this is now their
second encounter their first was nearly
six months ago at the 2016 Tata Steel
chess tournament as we can see just to
our right ways rating 2696 at 17 years
young not a bad rating it has been as
high as 27 34 I'm joking of course when
I say not bad it's more like exceptional
clearly one of the most promising young
players in the chess world today and a
name that will often spring about
whenever there's talk of a player
succeeding
Magnus Carlsen so let us see how their
second fight turn out deform Carlsen
replying with g6 modern defense
efore an ideal pawn center Bishop g7
Knight c3 these next couple moves retain
some flexibility with the black minor
pieces first d6 black wants to acquire a
little bit more information about
White's setup Bishop e3 securing d4 and
has a watchful eye already over the c5
strike the a6 preparing to expand on the
Queen side and I know we're just four
moves in but there is a reason why White
has held off on declaring the king
Knight f4 white wants to have a few
ponds contribute to control the center
and only then will the knight tuck
himself in right behind the pawn b5
preparing to fianchetto and make the
knight feel a little bit uneasy he can
now be kicked at any moment Knight f3
Knight d7 helping with a c5 advance
'if I've for the moment this Bishop is
biting on a rock plaque sees this and
we'll look to chip away at the white
center and free the bishop if it should
be seven this is a strong piece maybe
even stronger now without a pawn on e4
since it sees a little bit more of the
white King side squares white sees this
in looks too with Bishop d3 offset the
Bishop c5 striking at the center Bishop
efore LightSquared Bishop Saar now gone
black continues to develop and now we
have a bit of a direct line kicking off
with move 11 D take C D takes e breaking
up this deaton the e5 and F for
structure helping out the bishop as a
result this pawn is passed however and
is pushed c6 and I'd have six the
Queen's are now exchanged the Knights
are exchanged spawn is still around and
just a single square away from queening
have to defend them and what to do well
for black number one priority is hunt
down this pun but how do you do that
King d7 it's important not to go with
the common here and just castle he needs
to play an active role King d7 is the
way to do it within king c6 you don't
want to stay on this open file for too
long can't Bishop a5 just anticipating
King c6 with its tempo anyhow Knight f5
it's important not to as black recognize
there's there's this tension here and oh
can I not just win upon no you can't do
that if you grab the pawn right now
after queenside castle rook d8 if you're
trying to get the knight in the ball
game now now it's too late the rooks now
have firm control over the D file
squares and how does this Knight ever
cross
towards the queenside to try and
dislodge the bishop camp the big trouble
for Team Black in fact it's losing
computers already suggesting to cash out
and well guess who just turned into
pacman short story here is to knock all
pawn grabbing and instead improve the
quality of your pieces as soon as
possible this night I know he's on the H
file but he needs to drift over towards
the Queen side to dislodge this guy here
as otherwise black is all tied down and
can't really he doesn't have any free
pieces until this guy is off the board
Knight f5 looking for d6 pivot square
and then one of these two to strike at
the bishop Queen side council king c6
rook d8 preparing now to double the
knight is there just in the nick of time
to post on d6 looking for these two F
takes F takes and now white just doubles
rooks it's important not to try and stop
a move like Knight c4 if you can't stop
both of these Knight moves there's no
reason to waste any time with this move
right away just get another piece
involved at this point black next to me
white realizes that the C pawn will not
live so rook to d1 Knight see for white
now turns his attention towards the e5
pawn bishop c3 rook takes c b3
undermining the e5 pawn Knight e3 the
rook is under fire so where do we go
with them nowhere it's a lot of
calculation a pretty deep line here
white can actually allow Knight takes
rook Bishop takes e5 was played Knight
takes rook now this rook is being
threatened so first we play rook d6
that's a check King b7 and now we take
the bishop I'd like to just point out an
alternative for black something that may
run through your mind is at this moment
here after the rook d6 move suppose the
King goes to c5 maintaining pressure on
the rook preparing to meet Bishop takes
Bishop with King takes rook well let's
see about that
even if the King is going to c5 instead
of the game move King b7 we still grab
the bishop on g7 if King takes rook now
notice we can take the rook in the
corner and now there's two threats in
mind one is to scoop up the night and
play a position where it's the two minor
pieces versus the rook and the other is
to skewer the king and rook by way of e5
and the knight cannot move and defend
the e5 square so best is to let's say go
to e3 we would have a check and this
balanced I imagine still a little bit
tricky
endgame so that's what would happen if
king c5 is played there would be a way
to maintain material equality King b7
was played Bishop takes g7 rook g8 and
Bishop to d4 doing a very good job in
restricting the night there's only one
square he can make use of and he hops
right to it but for the moment black is
in a restricted position the rook has a
responsibility he has to watch over the
knight so white looks to disrupt the
coordination between the rook and the
night with these next couple moves first
rook b6 check where does the King go
this is a good way to lose discover
check there goes your rub King c8 Bishop
e5 how strong a piece this is striking
it the rook maintaining pressure on the
night how do you move the rook and still
defend the night oh here's our square
right
not so fast because here's another
skewer
there goes your rook you're losing you
can't move the rook black recognizes
this and says okay well I might as well
just get this dummy into play to d8 king
b2 pressure on the night
there's no rush with staking the rook
what white would really like to have
happen is play position where it's the
two minor pieces in a rook versus two
rooks Knight d5 only now
does white grab the rook King takes rook
takes pawn white is now up upon five
versus four however after King b7 rook
to a3 we got some awkward pieces here
for white and I don't know if it's too
soon to try and point out some pattern
but when I reviewed their first
encounter I saw I'm noticing a little
similarity between the first these first
two games that being when one side has a
material plus you know decide with the
material plus has some not so great
pieces now they're not so active pieces
you know this guy right here in a3 you
know this is not his dream Square yes
it's not really functioning like a rook
for the moment but white is up upon 93
and at this point how to say white needs
to breathe the rook needs some more
squares so we have the move see for a
good move to try and disrupt the pawn on
d5 if he's no longer there we can see a
rook pivot on a five and then there's at
least some nice possibilities along the
fifth-ranked B take C and at this point
up into this move 34 it's been very
level however there's a
issue with White's next move Knight to
e5 when is the big issue with this move
well it's allowing black to enter with
the rook give a check give another check
and then have this pawn live
he remains past a better move instead of
Knight to e5 is to play b4 and have the
rook strike at the night there's some
possibilities to next improve the rook
now that again there isn't a pond on b5
there is next some IDs of rook a 5 into
c5 and you could try to track the pawn
down in that way but by playing Knight
to e5 at this point here black will find
it much easier to hang on to this past
pawn one who has some great depth
clearly just a couple squares away you
know White has connected passed pawns
but just having this one pawn with much
higher quality yeah he's a dangerous
pawn and these guys are still the white
pawns are still 5 moves away from
promoting compared to the one pawn two
squares away from queening so he becomes
a number one priority he's a serious
serious threat without question King c5
Knight d6 knight c6 we have a check King
b5 and what do we do here for black
we're trying to push this pawn right so
what should we do just get the rook out
of the way and push the pun hang on if
you do that you've already fallen for a
matin three this uh this last move by
white is throwing a serious threat rook
a7 king b6 rook c7 let me put it on
board if black plays rook D
- here clearing the way that's what we'd
have check here and there's nothing that
will stop rook here or Rupp to a8 next
for checkmate
of course black sees this
hande runs with the king preparing to
meet rook a7 the move played in the game
with King d6 getting out of that little
mating net okay for securing the night
is black with f5 king b6 whites black
scoops up upon we have a check in there
and it's a race a four they still have a
ways to go but got to try to get those
pawns pushing rook a to not best
computers eyes immediately coming over
to target the beep on his best but black
is there okay with rook to a2 getting
behind the furthest advance bond I know
he's just a single square more advanced
than the one on b3 but getting right
behind that furthest advanced pawn a5
rook to be two now and we have King c7 a
better try for white here is to play b4
hanging on to that pawn and not try for
this little trick there's a little trick
involved with the King c7 move after
rook b2 king c7 this pond should not be
captured right now and it wasn't
captured in the game but if it's
captured right now do you see the little
tactic that white house if you'd like to
go ahead pause the video what would you
play in this position as white
okay the move here should black have
captured on B three would be rook takes
Knight widths check and it's opening up
this square for a fork this endgame is
actually pretty interesting it would in
fact turn out to be a draw I'm not going
to play all the way through it but yeah
you just have to trust me that
eventually this is turning out to be a
draw
so there is that little trick rook takes
pawn this is a way that y could be
saving that little tactic 94 black
doesn't bite doesn't grab the pawn but
instead plays the move Knight c5 very
strong move preventing this pawn from
advancing also there's ideas where the
knight can be the one who maybe captures
on b3 and from b3 he's helping out
support that final advance helps to
support that final square c1 rook c4
Knight a6 it looks like this Knight has
is going astray and will be trapped
he'll be captured and that is what
happens but black has something up his
sleeve after king b6 rook takes B check
black is allowing the knight to be
captured why
what must black do here he's down a
piece but King d5 notice the awkward
placement I know it's just for this is
just a you know one one position here
but here's another instance where at
least from the moment white is that
material but these pieces a little bit
awkward King to d5 and how are you
saving these guys can't to give up some
material here this is a nice try with
rook to be four you know if captures the
knight is there to recapture and you
know he'll be there to stop the pawn
this is also a position that would
result in a draw feel free to work that
out on your own you could just trust me
that that is the case but we don't have
to capture here after rook to b4 we
could just push the pawn and this is
what happens in the game black just gets
on with advancing the pawn and he will
queen white inserts a check
King to c5 we don't want to allow the
rook to pivot and get behind the pawn
rook takes rook black now gets a queen
an imbalance position a knight rook and
pawn versus a queen well there's also a
couple extra pawns over here this being
the more important of the two
he's the past pawn white needs to get
coordinated in this ending as soon as
possible otherwise you could very easily
see one of these pieces the night or up
be picked up the Queen giving a check
and hitting a loose piece Queen c4
Queenie form there's a fork
you got a block with the knight
Queen d5 main idea here for black is
what can I do to prevent the white pawn
from advancing so that I could buy
myself some time to advance my own past
pun Queen d5 stop say 6:00
if a6 is played here Queen d7 the king
has to move away from defense of the
rook and mate in just a couple so Queen
d5 white tries King c7 black Queen is
there to dislodge the white King King b7
Queen d7 check King to b8 and now this
Queen a very disruptive piece she has
done a very good job in kicking the King
away from defense of the rook this is
not a threat white is not able to push
this pawn successfully so yeah well in
another way to view it is there isn't
really a better post for the black Queen
at this stage you can't really improve
the quality of her position so now is
the time to get rolling with f4 and with
that move white resigns there's just too
slow not enough time not enough
coordination for the white side to try
and push through with the ape on the
computer points out Knight to be four
going to be our Queen to f5 a check can
be thrown in King to d4 but sure you
gave the King a check but now this
Knight is getting in the way of the pawn
and the F pawn will be rolling very very
soon in fact the a pawn can already be
picked up so there just isn't enough
coordination the timing is just not
there in order for white to pose any
serious threat with there passed pawn
this F pawn is a Black's passed pawn the
F pawn is the far more dangerous pawn so
interesting game very sharp game I don't
know if you guys also picked it up those
of you that have seen their first
encounter but
again I'm noticing just from these two
games this idea of one side when they
have a material plus they have a little
bit awkward pieces and just it's
interesting I saw that in their first
encounter a little bit in this game here
their first game in a while
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video let me know what you think
as usual in the comment section below
and as always I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you